Watch cree que no tengo ningún mérito en
tengo derecho a votar solo soy
puede que no esté en la familia adecuada en
buen lugar pero no tengo merito en
ser ciudadano francés y me parece
normal compartir con los que
no tan afortunado
[Música]
Dudé en votar por esta elección
presidencial y finalmente elegí
abstenerme de votar porque yo
no reconocer en el
sistema político no me reconozco
en estas elecciones han pasado diez años desde
me voy a francia que pretendo quedarme
en Francia durante algunos años más es
importante para mi participar
usted después es solo votando pero de
participar un mínimo en lo que será
tomado como una decisión
por la persona que será elegida
[Música]
¿O fue el primero en contactarme?
e intercambiamos solo por messenger
luego a mi pedido y de repente para quien
quería votar
y nombro a la persona para ello
necesito fotos acabo de responder
ok sabía que aceptaría
el candidato él o ella
quería sin discutir siempre y cuando
Pensé que no era un candidato.
que tenía demasiado discurso de odio pero
fue la única condición después de que yo
aceptó su elección en cualquier caso
Conozco gente que vive aquí.
por 10 años 15 años que tienen esposa
que tienen opiniones de los novios que tienen
niños y que no pueden votar desde
hecho de un problema de naturalización
de acceso a la sala de estar y luego cuando
incluso ellos pasan su vida aquí y ellos
están integrados aquí
[Música]
donde los dias hoy hay
artículos o políticas que piensan
esto o lo de los extranjeros mientras nosotros
no pidas lo peor no los dejamos
defenderse no es expresarse
ellos cuando no los dejamos mostrar lo que
que los deseen como sociedad en
Francia
[Música]
cuando eres extranjero en francia
est con la vida unos años en francia nos
está directamente relacionado con todo lo que
sucede todo lo que se configura
por el poder así que no veo por qué
no tendríamos nuestra opinión
Fingiré que es mi voto
a menos que y creo que haré uno
foto pequeña para mi amigo o algo
algo así para demostrarle que tengo
respetó su elección